hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects we're going to
be looking at a bunch of effects that
are just wild crazy and maybe even a
little
awful how do how do you think they did
this the question we're all trying to
ask ourselves are these bad because they
wanted them to be bad or was it a happy
accident and we're also going to be
looking at some mindblowing MCU visual
effects that you've probably never seen
before
just as a heads up little update to you
guys it's no longer called VFX artist
react it's just called bfx I heard that
too did you hear what he said welcome
back to another episode of
VX oh wait
really it's okay honestly I kind of like
it this is the first episode of VFX yeah
no one else is doing it anymore so we
decided hey why not let's give it a shot
VX here we
[Music]
go
well now where did you come from so this
has been shared with me a bunch over the
last couple months and I don't know how
to feel about it the movie is straight
up called bad CGI Gator so it's tongue
and cheek obviously then yeah so I guess
the thing here is that this is a parody
of like this type of movie yeah it's a
parody of all the super cheap terrible
horror films basally you know but how do
you make every shot uniquely bad that's
the thing that's the challenge I would
see with a film like this so let's break
down how this Gator is bad if they're
leaning into it there's probably things
they're doing intentionally to make it
worse it's not that bad they actually
match the lighting look at that that
shot there like that's actually a decent
render of the Gator the lighting match
as
[Music]
well there's even some depth of field
here and it seems to kind of like Match
Into the grass a little bit with those
back feet well it's double depth of
field cuz the shoes are in focus and
then the tip of the snouts out of focus
oh my God you're and then it goes back
in focus a little deeper into there's
two different focal planes here it's
like there's just enough effort put into
it where it kind of technically works
but it's not something you'd see from
like a VFX Studio yeah
[Music]
okay that's pretty good though I
was I was about to say it's not the
worst and then it cut to the shot
without any Shadow it was just floating
obviously this is a bad V effect shot
but the CGI technically not that bad
like you said in the previous shot
you're seeing elements of depth of field
in this one you're seeing elements of
motion blur like they're incorporating
elements of a good render to me though
that is so the magic of the good bad is
like the things that you would never
think to do if you had like an artist's
sensibility see that's the that's what
it comes down to True Badness is the
things you never think to do yes when
filmmakers are really trying to make
something of quality they're just going
to try and make everything of quality so
that's easy but when you're making it
intentionally bad and we the audience
know that when we first see it you get
the initial response of oh haha that's
bad but we've got 90 minutes to fill
here so how do you keep getting worse
and that's the perfect pivot point for
that curtain shot where now it's
floating in the air oh
shitu it's so bizarre because there's no
Shadow from the gator and yet his right
hand looks to be composited behind some
of the grass this is what I'm saying
though it's like at what point do you
cut yourself off if you're making it
intentionally bad putting the foot
behind the grass like clearly there's
some forethought there this isn't the
sort of bad that comes from amateur
skill they should rename it to decent
CGI Gator decent CGI Gator I'm sorry we
we sorry you guys you guys made a decent
CGI
Gator it could be worse in a good way
this is almost an example of like VFX
appropriation where it's like they
should have hired real
nephews to do the effects but I can tell
that's not what they did you know the
world has at least hundreds if not
thousands of nephews out there like
they're watching YouTube tutorials and
they know blender they got it installed
last week they can do 3D animation okay
that's who they need to hire if they
want to make bad effect appropriation
from the nephews oh my God finally a
cause I can get
behind yeah think about the nephews
welcome back happy New Year and before
we get back to more clips I'd like to
talk about today's sponsor better help
it's a new year and this is a great time
to start setting goals my goal this year
is to make more music become more
confident making music and I even signed
up for a music class to help me do that
if you've got any goals a therapist can
help you set those whether that's a
smart goal specific measurable
attainable relevant and time bound or if
your goal is something like Stress
Management anger management or any other
challenges in your life a therapist can
help with that better help lets you have
therapy over phone call over video call
or over messaging whatever is most
comfortable for you to get started you
fill out a questionnaire and then they
match you one of over 30,000 therapists
in their Network in most cases in 48
hours or less and if you feel like your
therapist isn't a great fit there's no
extra fees for switching all you do is
hit one button and they match you with a
new one a lot of us have gone through
the experience of having to like break
up with a therapist and then start the
whole process over again and with better
help you never have to deal with that so
if you would like to get started with
better help join over 4 million people
who've started using betterhelp to make
positive changes in their life by going
to www.b betterhelp.com Corridor crew
clicking that link supports the channel
and it also gives you 10% off your first
month all right I think it's time we uh
check out what those guys are getting up
to let's go let's go but uh speaking of
good bad have you guys heard of big
shark
no who's ready for a fight YouTube
what's your name big shark is Tommy we's
latest film really this is this is the
latest as of this is 23 the guy who made
the room was like hi Mark yep here's a
Shar I'm so confed hi
Shar I think Tommy is now at this point
leaning into it and again presenting
what he believes to be funny about the
room so this is about I think it's about
a just a giant shark that is kind of
terrorizing the
city uh um there's shouldn't there be
more than
that I think there's another woman more
than that oh there trailer number one so
maybe there's maybe there's more juice
big shark trailer number two
yeah look at that oh my God what's going
on water oh it's okay hold up though
this shot where the streets flooding
isn't the worst no that looks de man
it's decent I mean I think your
expectations are that it's going to be
bad the masking on the the water yeah
that's that's pretty good no
splash oh look at that they're catching
the reflection though look at that and
it's not just direct reflection it is
actually being
displaced whoa oh yeah I could get into
this man I could give this looks like it
could be a good time is a lover of this
this type of movie One filmmaker maybe
stands above the I think I think I can
confidently say one filmmaker stands
Above the Rest oh it's the guy uh do you
know who I'm talking about he directed
all the Jurassic World
movies no we are talking about Neil
Breen Neil Breen is an independent
filmmaker who writes directs produces
does all the art does all the effects
like he's he's a oneman band he's
honestly the spirit of the high school
filmmaker like manifested as as an adult
this is twisted pair his film his second
to last film from
2018 maybe we need some sound there's
style to this already I'm digging
this my name is Kade my opinion on
he just like ran into a like a mental
brick
[Laughter]
wall I don't have what you
have but you could
[Music]
have obviously he's shooting everything
on a green screen but instead of using
videos as a background it's just all
just pictures single still frame
pictures it kind of reminds me of like a
like an old pointand click adventure
game or something like that
yes no no
no Jesus Christ I thought he was going
to eat it how do how do you think they
did
this how do you think they did this
effect I said they but it's Neil how do
you think Neil did this effect I think
Neil was on the first floor he ran and
jumped and landed and then he used some
of the previous frames from the running
and jump to transition from the second
floor to the
first in fact I've done a slight L
better version of that
shot times in my life yes this level of
bad this level of pacing like I don't
necessarily think you can do that level
on purpose unless you're an absolute
genius or unless you don't care unless
you don't unless you're so free and pure
that you understand that film making and
storytelling is ultimately a subjective
medium you know sometimes some of the
best filmmakers are those very efficient
ones that do so much with so little the
thing I love about what Neil does he has
this vision for a feature film he funds
it himself he turns a profit which is
crazy considering the market you know
acting that way or directing for that
kind of action is so difficult it's like
the only successes that I've seen are
things from people like Tim and Eric and
I'm here today with my good friend and
the star of my new film the pilgrims
grum this is like this is like ultimate
good bad yeah hi Mr tennis thanks for
having me and thanks for directing me me
in the
pilgrims well how does it feel to bring
the story of the pilgrims to the big
screen like right my face
hurts I don't know how they managed to
like balance it out with this obviously
it's janky on purpose but like it lands
it sticks The Landing it's yeah cuz
here's the thing like everything about
this animation it popping in after a
frame of not being on you know the
facial animations just being like a
constant blend shape between two like
the design of this dude too
like her eyeline you know yeah oh my
gosh it's so good
cack crackers and snacks crackers and
snacks I'm going start doing that dude
crackers and snacks crackers
and everything's wrong but just the
perfect amount of wrong yeah like that's
the other thing when you look at bad CGI
Gator it's like these look like gator
animations but when this guy talks it's
like the eyes are like uncomfortably
bulging out and like the throat is like
the tongue is yellow and only emerges
when it Clips through the like it was it
was literally animated without any
concern for the tongue no one does it
quite as good as Tim and Eric there's
few shows that made me laugh this hard
we've talked about good bad in TV we've
talked about it in movies but we haven't
talked about it in commercials and this
is a commercial that is still airing to
this day it's from Morango Casino Resort
and the the idea of this it's a casino
resort Morango is made for
everybody you like high stakes black
that was a decent transition fine what
do you think about this one in the high
limit VIP
[Laughter]
room they just need like a grunting
stomach
but wait there's a there's a post credit
scene there's a post credit scene Good
Times
forever sorry it takes a
[Applause]
second you're you're watching TV and
you've experienced this trauma of this
this brutal morph take place and you
think you're done once the logo hits but
they got one more for you one little
extra bit of PTSD for the road yeah how
do you think this was actually executed
I'm curious well okay the camera comes
in lands switch out the actors everyone
is continuing to be B basically not
moving but there's a tiny bit of motion
with the people you think they're
they're more from the background yeah
they are they're more from the
background as well that woman's arm on
the right kind of like morphs in notice
they also push in to get rid of as many
people as possible I think that was a
digital push in M yeah digital zoomed
ramping they speed ramping it like look
at they're like they kind of freeze on
the left side there too totally totally
yeah so as they get to that point
they're basically freezing it or like
extreme speed ramping it obviously with
the way everything is going these days
there's always a Cinematic Universe
right we've seen it all the time we'
seen shows and movies too is there a
Morango Casino Cinematic Universe Sam
there is wait Morango Casino
[Music]
Universe the MCU there is there is a the
one true
MCU the true MC uh so yeah look who we
start with we start with the person we
morph into at the end of the first one
you're right oh my God the continuity
it's continuity man a lot of thought
went into this it's some good times and
great
have a see who we who do we get next
ready 3 two 1 wait what is wait why did
they blur everyone in the background it
was all blurry I think it's probably
because there was too much like it was
too obvious they're
like wait I I want to see the little
post credit
[Laughter]
scene they got know post just he's so
proudly sitting dude I love it when it
goes out of focus the VFX artist just
like no and you see no not doing it and
you see you literally see them like
speed up in the background they start
moving so fast so that's the second one
there's a third brother oh this is like
uh what is that secret Invasion show
this is the latest addition to it where
they're all shape shifters Morango is
made for you pick up with our next hero
sitting down for a nice date until oh
blurred again my
husband and she's gone I don't know what
happened to her she got thanosed see
this is the problem with doing morphs is
that this is what you end up getting
when you don't put enough forethought
into the morph itself and you just like
are doing it like as is like there's the
Michael Jackson Black and White music
video where they're constantly morphing
back and forth but they were doing
things like lowering the hair on the
morph was very yeah it was motivated it
was very well thought out this one they
just gave up moring her and they just
like they just did a butt transition
wait wait wait you're right so I was
supposed to be the character and it's
just butt transitions to just a totally
different person yes is this the last
one no it's it's not let's play the
fourth and final oh no all right another
butt shot I guess yeah wait this it's
wait here we go your game is Blackjack
woo I
win the best one it's the tilt of the
head the
freaking all right is there a post
credit SC here watch this watch this
who is it oh we back in the
beginning it's a loop it's a loop dude
it never ends so he was never in the
shot she's really in the shot like
that's just an image of him go back to
him so he was comped in he's comped in
one of them is comped in he's comped in
cuz he's bigger yeah they must have had
him like walk in frame I'm right but I
can't prove it well he's got I mean they
did the hair really well if that's the
case they did but cuz he's probably
there actually she looks weirder to me
I'm willing to bet neither of them are
in the shot I was just going to see that
I think you're right cuz they're they're
like oh we can have perfect background
plates yeah oh my god look he's on a
green screen he's on a green screen
they're all on green screen yeah oh I
didn't expect to go this deep on this
I'm happy so her glass is also being
keyed out right there it disappears a
little bit cuz it becomes a little too
transparent and so it ends up getting
completely keyed out this is a very
common problem with trying to key out
something transparent on a green screen
so they filmed her walking in landing
now it's we're looking at a locked off
wide shot that they're digitally
cropping into and animating the camera
around but they put up a green screen
behind her so that they do that plate
and then they do his plate yeah it was
like they wanted to do this as often as
they could when they knew that the
camera was going to be static but they
also wanted to have a dynamic scene
which you wouldn't be able to do with
something like this yes yes it's been a
bit of therapy to bring this before you
guys cuz this has been haunting me for
quite some time I've never seen this
before thank you very much for bringing
my attention to the MCU it had to be
done Jordan you know he accidentally set
a URL to Christian that has some really
naughty stuff in it really cool too it
it wasn't for you guys can we just
delete watch it we're going to watch it
we shouldn't watch it head on over to CD
digital.com right now to see an extended
version of this episode it's a 2E free
trial $3.99 after that for every single
month and guess what if you're just
going to watch this on YouTube
subscriptions here they're free so why
not click the button right now wow guys
it's kind of rare that we do an
exclusively bad CGI episode but if you
have other juicy clips that are in that
bad category that you'd like to share
with us leave a comment down below cuz
we'd love to do it again yeah not just
TV or movies but commercials as well
everything is welcome
Morango you'll get it later everything
everything